robert ist sehr gut das brauchst auf
jeden fall definitiv später wurde seine
freunde und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten folge vom mega projekt was jetzt
schon so lange angekündigt war und jetzt
ist es endlich los gegangen und ich
nehme sofort die erste folge zusammen
auf mit dem der gerade ins bett läuft
hey hey hey hey du bist auch irgendwann
mal da guck mal was rollen kann
geschrieben kraft da und dort sofort an
regeln beachtet recht als erstes läuft
man hier immer hier rein hier ja das ist
immer der anfang
das immer das ist immer das erste was
man tut ja das ist immer das
allerwichtigste das muss man vor jeder
folge einfach machen
nein natürlich nicht wir hatten alle
zusammen eigentlich einen termin ab
gemacht wenn wir eine anfangs folge
aufnehmen
und da war ich nicht da alle ran da
außer ich das war irgendwie doof und
deswegen hat sich den er jetzt dazu
bereit erklärt mir ganz kurz zu erklären
was die denn hier alles so veranstaltet
haben et cetera pp
wir haben immer noch 30 ich stehe hinter
dir siehst du mich nicht ich bei mir
connect also tronic sich bitte bis zum 3
ja es ist immer noch derselbe tag das
heißt das läuft hier schon ein paar
stunden eigentlich ist der crafter der
chronik ist da hinten auch das heißt es
geht schon als ein
sein weg dass man einfach mal aufgeht
und manchen aufnimmt um essen spielt und
ihr also was ihr natürlich verpasst habe
an informationen ist ein bisschen dass
wir hier eine stadt jetzt haben wo jeder
einzelne grundstück hat hier voll ist
der marktplatz sozusagen genau hier an
platz nehmen es einfach marktplatz
bekommt von seinem grundstück angelaufen
hier wo ich stehe es fängt mein
kunststück ungefähr an und kommt kraft
will jetzt auch ein grundstück bekommen
und das ist in sein lager
kurz das ist hier vorne links da wo die
ganzen kritischen und fokussieren das
natürlich nicht so schön
ok de natur lokal auf mein grundstück
strafe wenn man das mutwillig macht dann
muss man eine folge lang aufnehmen im
gefängnis sonst wird man gewarnt
das heißt er muss 15 minuten lang im
gefängnis aufnehmen das aber erst recht
auf der ganzen welt mitnimmt
ja ich habe versucht ja dass sie nicht
hinkommen sehr gut also dass ich hier
ist auf jeden fall mein grundstück
genommen bisschen dunkel aber das liegt
eher an der tageszeit gerade wird
natürlich noch alles schön ausgeleuchtet
hier allerdings dass meine erste folgen
wie ich schon gesagt habe ich diesen
gemeinsamen termin verpasst hier ist gar
kein gras blätter dorf fiel dann
brauchst jetzt neues menschen noch als
kleine information weiß ich noch gar
nicht gesagt hat bei mir ist natürlich
ganz normal die vierte folge hier also
wenn ich welche fragen hier hängt das
schild wieder neu an
nicht nur bei konkreter die erste folge
bei mir schon immer gesagt dass ich
alles so durcheinander dass wenn ich das
kann schon mal bei mir in die erste sein
bei denen dann die vierte wir werden das
jetzt auch machen dass ich das ganze
hier in zwei folgen teilen werde also
215 berliner wird das eine folge seien
also 30 minuten
und ja bla bla auf jeden fall brauchst
du sachen ein ding von amg ist das dein
hund der sich das ist nicht mein hund
ich glaube nicht nennen wenn du ihn
jetzt schlägt und explodiert dann jetzt
hier
dann wäre das meine schuld ich müsste
alles ordentlich aufräumen also nicht
sowie natürlich die orte h2o
vor das ist echt knapp oder so gut doch
aber noch ein zweiter glaube ich oder
dass man scheint er gut also wir haben
also ihr habt auch festgelegt dass man
nur abbauen darf hundert meter von der
stadt entfernt
genau damit die stadt ordentlich schön
bleibt und so hier ist übrigens auch
schon bald auch glaube ich ist so
typisch krieg ist nicht fair das war
dass die rechte typisch kripo noch mäßig
aus na gut ich brauche auf jeden fall
erstmal sachen das heißt wo kann ich
etwas abbauen ich möchte am liebsten
erstmal warten wer lesen ich wurde
übrigens am ende letzte folge gekillt
das heißt ich habe auch fast nichts mehr
aber ich guck mal was nicht noch in
meiner dings habe ich glaub ich habe
zumindest ein schwert in meiner tour
ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz was hier
was ist hier kommt eine taverne oder so
man die szene genau das ist unsere unser
gemeinschaftshaus da stimmen wir dann ab
wie hart wir kompakter bestrafen und so
genau hier ist also dran cavs
grundstücks grundstück denn hier weitere
auf dem berg ist surprise
neben der letzte preis alljährlich ist
luke place blutfleck der ist hierbei der
fluss zwischen da vorne das ganz große
das ist komme also dass jetzt alles
komme das ist schon riesig da ist ein
clip an gomez mont stück was auf den vom
tisch
deswegen doch wieder ganz schnell weg
hier dieses grundstück hier ist das von
den er schon relativ groß
ja aber nicht aber sie kommt hier habe
ich zurückhaltend wo bist du denn
eigentlich
einen schub von menschheit da was gerade
einfach mal weg gute dürftig mit sachen
hier raus aus seiner kiste dürftig nicht
mehr dürfte für mich aber ich habe
selbst wie du siehst habe ich auch gar
nichts wir müssen auf jeden fall los um
in sachen zu holen
jaja meine hier die manns grundstück
feiere ich auch für richtig dass jeder
der hat einfach von fetten baum des
lebens gerade bei nacht nicht so gut
aber ist sehr schön und das ist der onyx
grundstück ist einfach da so eine insel
ne richtig mit hält sich eigentlich alle
teilnehmer und hat meine lage hier
kaputt gemacht durch seien heftig ich
bin auf jeden fall schon sauer auf ihren
das hat auch mit vorkommnissen der
letzten folge zu tun aber dass er dann
einfach bei den danach gucken und dazu
auch ein guter übergang wenn jetzt bei
dir danach gucken wollten ihr kennt
jeder nicht alle stehen in der
beschreibung die mitspielen
nitrate steht in der beschreibung die so
nett war und das ganze hier hosten
fiete wies download steht in der
beschreibung hier ist ein zombie ich
habe beschwert du lieferst du das kart
nicht bindend genommen ich hatte jetzt
das habe ich das habe ich jetzt aus
meiner tour karte
wir beschäftigen uns zwei minuten damit
einen keeper zu töten und dann kommt ihr
noch die glorreiche idee hält übrigens
fast kein essen mehr ist aber auch kein
ende hat nur noch eineinhalb herzen
fällt mir ganze und es macht das richtig
charakter weil wir können wir müssen uns
einen betten machen
wir müssen jetzt eigentlich mal
irgendeine richtung weglaufen und uns da
irgendwas bauen müssten eigentlich mag
ich hoff mal wenn ich hier hinten leute
raus laufen weil ich glaub jetzt am
meisten wald und kümmern leichtesten zu
in sachen machen
ja wenn ich laufen könnte wäre schon gut
du kannst auch nicht mehr laufen ich
möchte mal lange er das schweigen
hüllten und dann kann ich das essen ist
auch 14 dass es nicht das bringt aber
doch nicht so viel nehme mir auch nicht
scheiße aber ich kann ganz gut sprinten
ich habe drei keulen okay von wo darf
ich jetzt abbauen also wir haben gesagt
signal 100 100 blogger entfernt
allerdings noch ein bisschen laufen
passen kuba nehmen gewesen
laufen kannst du ruhig machen ich nicht
wir diese bäume hier bin ich sehr schön
diese libero ich würde sagen also aus
dem wald hier noch nichts aber alles
danach können wir hier als abholzen dow
erholten jetzt mal den baum hier direkt
und dann weil da trifft sich vielleicht
eigentlich ganz gut dass ich jetzt noch
mal mit ihr zusammenspiel weil ich muss
auch wieder von vorne anfangen so zu
sagen hat zwar ein paar es aber mehr
auch nicht alles aufgebaut
er hatte nämlich schon das ein oder
andere ist ein anderer der der modell
schon gut schon ungerecht wartet auf
jeden ambulant was ich so gehört habe so
jetzt erstmal schwert machen wir hier
sind sowas von viele schweine die
mädchen am liebsten alle abtöten
ja und danach brauchen wir ein ofen
damit wir auch das auch nicht warten
können uns voll verschwinden
ja und ich habe auch gedacht dass ich
mir theoretisch eine rolle dabei ich
habe auch ein relativ großes grundstück
und kanada noch eine farbe drauf zimmern
sache ist dann allerdings nur die wo ich
jetzt auch fragen wollte darf mir die
dann ein anderer wegschnappen die
schaden und nähe also was mit einem pass
auf was in der stadt ist sozusagen
frieden also darf man nichts wegnehmen
da muss man sich freundlich benehmen usw
werden ist übrigens der crafting mensch
also brauchst keine baum ja und wir
haben auch wieder haben auch viele
gefragt hey was habt ihr denn das alles
so für plug-ins darin ihr seht schon
hier wenig draufgeht planescape reduce
150 mg blabla das ist fies leid diesmal
also nicht das ganz krasse was ich mit
ungespielt darauf hatte sondern halt
denkt so normal ist sage ich mir noch
mal so häufig krank halbwegs kraft genug
mit die damit das einfach stabiler läuft
und so weiter aber wir können uns da
auch alle in die kommentare schreiben
was wir da überhaupt alles so bauen
sollen was es da für coole sachen gibt
weil wir kennen uns wahrscheinlich
weniger aus als ihr das habe ich auch
schon immer die ganze zeit gepredigt and
the beast wenn irgendwelche tipps habt
könnt ihr einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
das einzige was wir erfahren hat ist
dass sich wrabetz holen sollen das dann
eben was anderes macht und sich kennen
das schon so ein bisschen aber auch noch
nicht jetzt so krass sie geht auf jeden
fall so 20.000 verschiedene ärzte und es
gibt auch 20.000 verschiedene neue items
ich auch dazu gekommen sind ich werde
auf jeden fall erstmal soll so schuhe
versuchen zu machen weil wenn man mit
den schulen dann irgendwo runter fällt
dann kriegt man keinen fall schaden und
kann auch die kann man nicht auch
irgendwie ein jetpack macht ihre genauen
jetlag geht auch nie aber dafür braucht
man dann kannst du halt super blöcke
höher springen kann es auch so fliegen
und so wie du musst alle doch mal kohle
reinpacken glaube ich weil sonst das
keine energie und halt noch so andere
sachen bis so eine kleine dampfmaschine
ja genau das ist als wenn du dir
flugzeug auch noch geschnalzt braucht er
auch treibstoff ich wollte mir gar keine
kohle spitzhacke machen das auch ganz
gut sein dass hier funktioniert auf
jeden fall gibt es ja ganz viele stellen
wie zum beispiel das jetzt nämlich kein
eisen sondern kopper jakub kuba kann man
sich auch ausrüstungsteile machen
rüstungsteile sind glaub ich sogar
besser als rüstungs teile sein weiß ich
nicht ob ich glaube schon
ich mache ein ofen damit wir uns hier
mal das schweinefleisch paten können
wenn du welches hast kannst es hier rein
tun
ich habe als er cholera getan also
spielen jetzt mehr oder weniger zusammen
das wort ich mein ganzer englisch
wortschatz kommt er nur von daher wenn
irgendwelche videos schauen oder
fernsehserien irgendwie sowas
und wenn er keins ortet darin vorkommen
dann weiß es nicht
aus der englischen der schule gar nicht
einhalten der schule lehre auf jeden
fall nicht das kommt echt alles nur vom
von medienkonsum auf englisch oder
englischen texten oder schreiben echt
krass wenig in englisch einfach das alte
man lernt so dieses grundlegende
englisch aber gesprochen wird davon fast
gar nichts und vor allem kann kommt es
natürlich auch ganz ganz auf die lehrer
an aber wenn halt der lehrer kacke ist
und man eigentlich da nicht sehr nett
formuliert was weil bei uns zum beispiel
machen wir nur gruppen arbeiten oder wir
reden auf deutsch und das war so wenn
man stattdessen englische diskussion
machen würde dann denke ich mal würde
man auch deutlich besser noch englisch
lernen aber so wie das bei uns
praktiziert wird nicht ihr können uns in
die kommentare schreiben auf ihre puppen
englischunterricht hat oder ob das für
euch die neuen anders ist weil ich denke
es ist in
es kommt halt darauf an in welcher du
stirbst rande ich hab auch mal ein paar
ist extra dicken spitze ist es deine ja
die brauche ich nicht mehr selbst den
stein holz wettgemacht
klein chmelar freute ich wollte dich
töten so meins meins meins meins scheiße
was essen also bei uns dass so wie wir
hat englisch lk ich weiß nicht was da
auch immer stärker wir haben leider kein
lka system mehr sondern auch viele als
etwas das sinn
das heißt du wählst sein profil und das
dann alles in die ecke sozusagen
vorgegeben also ich hab s gesellschaft
wissenschaftlern kopieren da ist dann
die pole und erdkunde geschichte und das
hauptfeld wie vor das ist wirtschaft und
politik das heißt in allen ländern
unterschiedlich bei uns heißt es wipo
hergesell stieß kunden heißt es
vielleicht so heißt es sowie
sozialwissenschaften
das ist auch so politik so was alles
halt also bei mir ist es durch habe ja
deutsch und englisch also sprachlichen
schwerpunkt schwerpunkt der als es bei
uns wenn schon es gibt dann auf
physikalischen wert schwerpunkt wenn man
dann irgendwann auch bei uns gezeigt
mathe und physik und chemie blabla wie
so was ist dann
physikalischer schwerpunkt und bei uns
im englischunterricht ist es echt so
dass wir haben fünf oder sechs
wochenstunden und wir sprechen
eigentlich immer englisch und auch wenn
man vom unterricht mit der lehrerin
spricht oder so muss man halt auch
englisch sprechen hat die komplette zeit
auch untereinander und werden die
lehrerin das mitkriegt dass man nicht
englisch spricht dann muss man irgendwie
was muss man machen was man kriegt auf
jeden fall nicht auf jeden fall der
meinung hilft mit blattmann man lernte
schon aber man lernt was mich als
aufregt ich war irgendwann mal vier
wochen in
london nur in sommerferien vor einem
summer school sowas ja genau das ist das
da lernt man viel mehr als in den ganzen
jahren englisch davor wirklich weil man
lernt einfach viel mehr
diese sprache die dauer wirklich
gesprochen wird wenn man sich wirklich
mit den leuten auseinander setzen muss
und dem in der schule lernt man will ja
bla bla event der import und eis
blockiert dass es muss mit ja so was
alles das ist ja das ist zwar gut dass
man das so lernt aber im endeffekt
bringt es eine relativ wenig jetzt zu
sagen aber das einzig sinnvolle was man
eigentlich der schule machen kann es
möglichst viel englisch sprechen damit
einfach die sprachpraxis hat damit man
schnell auf welche fragen eigentlich
nicht irrenhaus überlegen muss wie waren
das jetzt mit der grammatik und so ja
genau das ist einfach dass es eben und
da möchte ich kann auch echt gar kein
ich hab gar roten baum gefällt was das
heißt eine möhre dran kleben die möhren
recaro das ist aber gut ist sehr gut
aber wo ich abgebaut da das brauchst auf
jeden fall definitiv später bei roger
waters an
hey was geht
kratz mich gerade kabarettist daraus
kann sich später aber machen und aus
diesem rubber das brauchst du zum also
dann damit diesen rabatt kann man da das
braucht man damit daraus muss man
schwarze welle machen und dann braucht
man auch kupfer und dann hat man
rhabarber cable womit diese kopper cable
damit musst du deine maschinen
miteinander verbinden als werden und
generator hast oder match race team zu
kopper kabel verbinden
da habe ich dann aber noch nicht da habe
ich ca 50 folgen für gebraucht ist das
hingekriegt
und dann kamen das megaprojekt und dem
verstand anwenden denkst du eigentlich
dass wenn du willst dass die schweine
samen bekommst und die dann pflanzen
kannst bei dir zu hause oder warum kills
wie die ganze schweine
ich brauche was zu essen
du bist vor allem vorne was voll stehen
im vordergrund blumen im vordergrund die
blumen ich wäre die und ich werde
übrigens und shader reinpacken ich weiß
allerdings zurzeit noch nicht wie das
funktioniert habe mich damit auseinander
gesetzt alles kaputt gemacht dass kein
fleisch du musst schon da rein lägen
nicht vor
denn ganz komisch nur wie viel fleisch
drin das nur von mir
keiner darf überleben wenn ihr mich
sehen das sterben die sofort